yo what's up I'm here with Lauren he is
my good friend from Romania and he is
this week's winners on a Wednesday so
welcome to the show Florian thank you
having me are you so welcome
Florin the reason I had you on the show
was because you came to England and how
many words of English could you speak
when you came to England I remember was
just a few words I can come down on my
finger for sure
really yes literally just hi hello thank
you no yeah yeah that's kind of stuff
okay
now fast forward a few years you're a
very successful businessman property
entrepreneur yes this is insane it is
I've seen the bank I know the stats why
don't you just tell us kind of what
you're doing now I mean how many
property deals have you done in the last
12 months right so since I joined
Academy heard there about six property
deals I flip through some investors
through some companies so yes yes six
property deals yeah you didn't hold on
to them
yes mate okay yeah you're you've also
got a plumbing business yes and when we
met it was going yeah I was on the point
oh yeah it was suffering a lot um what
did you turn over last year was 145 key
so you turned over 145,000 pounds yeah
and of that what was your net percentage
profit that was about between 20 25
percent and this year expected based on
our research and all the stuff supposed
to be doubled it's like poor familias
dude man coming from Romania to England
without speaking any English yeah - now
turn it over that kind of money quarter
of a million doing property deals that
is insane
it is insane I mean it would be so easy
for you to come up with excuses yeah it
was times when IDs find excuses and you
know I just but then I realize that he's
up to me if we'll work on that so
and we've also become really good
friends like we've traveled to Africa
together you've dined with some
celebrities yeah yeah okay
so why don't you just give some some of
the strategies techniques give us some
of the learning points oh right so when
I joined Academy remember I was on the
point to put down my business because
was was really struggling and yeah do
you take a lot of time and I didn't find
the right people and I was on the point
just to quit and that's it stuff
something else we have a quick chat and
he said just hold on or might be able to
help to put it up and running so I
realized that actually I have to kind of
implement in my people people working
with me a good mentality about the
business about how to relate to the
customers and most of the things I learn
is to add value to the customer so we
don't do business with the customer just
to make some money we actually adding
value to the customer we offer something
the people the customer they've feel
very comfortable with us you know taking
because some of the jobs are quite a big
job for just like a completely new
plumbing in the in the property new
boilers and all the stuff more the I
think that the key point was when I
realized it actually I have to offer
something to the customers something
which they will gain my trust and build
that relation with them once I start to
apply that thing as after starts to
change and then the same was with the
people I work with so I have at the
moment three guys working with me and
they won't really understand our
principle our code of honor we go there
we go there and we show respect we look
after the customer properties and we
give our best and obviously because of
that the feedbags they're all positive I
mean I did a few research on the last
few months on all the website where we
advertise the feedback that just five
stars you have selves five so I think
the fact that you put value to the
customers you build that relation with
them they feel very comfortable with you
so our dude you know what you're
speaking my language bro and the thing
is because your business was you're
about to close it it wasn't making any
money at all
and we spoke and I love what you just
said there about your team code of honor
it's one of the games because people
forget I'm a problem a property investor
but I'm a property entrepreneur yes and
I run a business and and you've the
Academy has been a life changing program
for you but but it's crazy because a lot
of people do this but you've taken the
academy you've not only applied the
lessons and techniques to your property
entrepreneur business but you've also
applied the techniques to your actual
pauling business which is just
absolutely blowing up your plumbing
business yes which is and that's a lot
of people a lot of people are doing that
on the academy
yes there's a lot of people doing that
so Albert Einstein says do not try and
be successful do not chase that money
try and be valuable and you took that on
board right yes fantastic talk to me
about your team code of honor within the
within your because you're the sole
director of the company yes
so you're the top guy Oh tell me about
tell me about how you manage to get one
or two terrible team players that we're
not helping at all I'm a bit teacher to
this really great team employees that
own the mission how did you do that
right so first I think you have to
implement in your people your vision why
do you want actually to achieve from
these business so what's your vision so
I learned that Robert Kiyosaki's have a
word that don't chase the money don't
try try to add value to people Chaya put
value into your customers and then the
manual come so I realized that and I
just said you know I want our company to
be well no because we are friendly
trusty you know accredited complaint so
we have all the other things together so
the people's when they call as they feel
very confident with us so then once I
apply all these to my team we go out for
any job we are all dressing the same
t-shirts nice blue bridle hook clean we
speak nice and polite with every
customer we explain twice if happens
some of the customer you know is quite
difficult to understand the way how the
things are working but we take that
extra time to explain to them so we
offered
our customer all our trust or our time
we go that extra mile is happening a lot
of them that we go extra mile even
sometimes without charging anything yeah
just to to make them so you call your
one action so you're on a mission to
give your customers
I give them a very good experience yes
good job for and then they start paying
and it's not paying on time and then the
staff your staff you start thinking this
is great I like this yeah they love the
job they love to be part corel company
that's one of the I mean I know one of
the things we talked about and some of
the mentoring that you've done also with
our coaches and their within the Academy
a lot of our business systemization and
things as well
which has been great but talk to me a
bit because this is a property channel
and I know you know the Academy is
primarily about property so talk to me
about the property deals you've done six
deals yes starting we're speaking very
bad English bother your English now he's
great man
your English is gray learning yeah it's
fantastic it's almost as good in fact
it's probably better than my English now
you're you know six deals like how did
you find 16 I know you've been doing hey
Cho Mohs you've got a rental rent on the
table at the - so we do with the deals
what happened was I think was my first
big day out yeah when I go and source
was to property in Rotherham so I was
like straight after the DfE so tell me
on the day I faked his father day fees
you booked a big day yes yes well I mean
it was first it was like kind of a joke
like I will not happen you know all this
I but once you start to see the property
make your numbers and realize that
actually they are you know stacked up or
everything okay start to call the agent
and you know the booking and you go out
it's true that you will find out out
there is not the really December izing
the pictures but that's why we have to
go see the property in order to where
when you'll bank the deal to send it to
the investor to be the best one possible
so yeah it was it was a good challenge I
saw the first I think was about eight or
nine properties just of them there was
good and from that day one of the deal I
just saw the next Monday so that was I
thinking that we care so the first deal
was so like in two three days after so
hold on yeah
it isn't raining yes what kind of deals
were you specifically looking for at the
moment or at that time at that time that
time was a HMO and a single net so you
didn't have the money to buy them nuts
but you thought if you can find the
deals then you'll be able to sell them
yes and make a fake yes okay so you're
looking for Haiti Moses single let's you
talked about you thought it was like
almost like a joke yeah tell me about
that I mean it was like something too
good to be true to be honest yeah and
what the idea of passing a day long for
a fake yes yes yes well you used all
these the you learnt how to find a day I
had to stuck a deal and you thought wow
I've learnt this quite easily
surely no one's gonna pay me any money
yes don't you know yeah yeah yeah and
that was think it was like too easy to
be true you know easy to find easy to be
there for you but many people struggle
may I have a bit of background in
construction industry si si si si si
came in UK I start in my own country I
was in double glazing industry for who
since I was seventeen so about seven
years and when I came here I start with
double glazing was 35 pounds a day was
nothing so then I start to move on to
the next level next so I kind of do all
all the trays like from painting to
tiling to everything so you've got the
scale of I to see a property to see if
it's a problem with that's a very
different scale to be lost at a property
yes yeah
are you what kind of property were you
looking for in order for it to start
what does it mean just a kadai wow the
first of all the property to be in that
condition that you don't have to spend
money right like to be in decent
condition already for the tenant to move
in on this maybe a little light
refurbish like a bit of painting but I
was looking for property to give to the
investor at least 25 30 % return of
investment so the first buy-to-let I
source it was twenty four percent return
of investment how the good how do you
work out a return on investment
all right he's about the money what you
put in and the money when you take it
back house which I learned today I mean
it was for me was the kind of new stuff
was like
investment doesn't be difficult yeah but
is no I mean yeah is is about the
investor all the money which will put in
like a deposit for the house sourcing
fee Legos fee and then what money will
take out yeah I mentioned as well that
before you would ever try and sell a
deal you have to do your you have to
view it you have to do what kind of due
diligence do you do to make sure the
property is good and is gonna run out
well alright so in that particular
property the property was already tenant
with the tenant in place so I did have a
few minutes Chad with with the lady and
she was a biscuit that like wow if he's
a new landlord
I said listen if we buy the house for
sure guarantee you'll stay there because
you know you are for easiest but even if
you if you if you don't have a tenant in
place I did check about three estate
agents about that particularly at the
particular house what will be the wrong
what kind of questions would you ask
about the area to make sure the area was
not too bad of an area yeah I mean I was
looking to a area where he's kind of
quiet not too busy not too dirty or that
kind of stuff schools around a bit of
shops yeah and if he's a family-friendly
area yes
you don't want an area that DSS only or
red light district yes respect because
you pass to the investor and you know
the investor they might have a high
expectation so you have to deliver that
say something else as well sometimes
people think just because a house is too
cheap that the people are cheap yeah
your might be dead but it not really no
because I always achieve that property
yeah but but I've got properties in
places like Middlesbrough and the house
is a lot 50 grands and that's the what
but the people there's the market there
and nice people they have jobs yes just
because you're cheap area does not mean
that the people are cheap it just means
that the area yes low price yes oh okay
so you find the property you make sure
that the rent is high yes right for a
low price maybe not the price as low as
you can get as below as 21 or 22 percent
below market and tell me that how do you
work out the truth because sometimes
people say oh this is below market value
but it's not really below market value
yeah yeah yeah you had that what we'd
that particular one
there was two properties like our
current members are guar was a number on
the door but just then the one on the
left was sold just about seven months
ago yeah and three houses down the
street again so in less than six months
was two or three properties so in that
particular street and the condition
there was the same like this one and
there was sold for about seventy five
and this one was I think I agree price
was about 58 or something like that so
yeah I kind of for sure when I said
there was below market value for sure
because on the same street on the same
line actually three properties in the
previous mount was so forth I love what
you said so importance people say it's
below market value but really it's
overpriced to start with so it's not
really the okay but you not you've you
know how to do the proper training
research so you find the properties
below market value it's giving you a
very high return on investment which is
fantastic once you've got that property
then how do you then sell that to an
investor well first property is solid to
buy Laura and harass and and one of the
great things about you out of all the
properties that you've sold six
properties I know you've done a couple
through Alastair and bottoming hide but
you've code eel sauce you found it on
the academes tell us about last one deaf
deaf that one actually was a direct mail
to the landlord yeah so I haven't seen
the property that actually was on action
on the market yeah and I have a
agreement with the with the with the
owner when we donor came back that
Florian will have to go through the
state edge and I don't know the reason
but yeah I will go for it later we find
out from this attached and actually
these auction property so then the
investor pull out no bubs
got it so we'll leave it how it is but
next day the the lender landlord called
me back
say flooring you know if you want to
still is still up if you want that's
still a price will just cut out the
estate agent so then I go back to one of
the
khadeem remember there's the deal
obviously the feel was a bit less yeah
so how much how much did you for
instance for that they're your first
1,500 1,500 so 1,500 pounds and that you
sold it to someone who you met on the
Academy yes yes why would an Academy
member that has the same training as you
why would they pay you 1,500 pound
defining property while they're not
following himself that particular guy
was from London yes so the property was
sourcing the Roeder ham which I think
it's about four hours five hours driving
yeah so I don't know maybe just because
he didn't have the the time yeah because
you need a bit of time to just go see I
guess even Audie even though I'd pay you
1500 pounds and I've got the knowledge
here so I guess it's sometimes a case of
people haven't got the time inclination
what was the deal ease up and he stuck
up and all the numbers are right I mean
that's the same position now looking for
a few rent rent and obviously if I will
find the right deal through someone of
the sorcerer I'll pay the fee yeah
talk to us about because you mentioned
robert kiyosaki at least once some of
the things you've learned of him talk to
me about your relationship with robert
kiyosaki
since joining in right so yeah well I
mean to be honest I heard about him and
I was playing a few times the cash flow
game before I came to to your first
crash course so I have a bit of idea who
the guy is and what he's doing but not
well but once I joined Academy I think
after the DfE you came up saying that
next samos know was that summer actually
because I joined Academy last year in
whatever April yeah and you said that
this summer I will go out in Africa for
your charity work and then we'll go to
South Africa to meet Kiyosaki and I was
like come out really slowly slowly we
get that date
when it did happen whoa I mean the guys
is a massive entrepreneur I mean what I
really adored him was the fact that he
really invests in the financial
education these days I mean this is I
think is one of the hugest problem in
the in the world I will say because you
know we all go to school but we don't
learn anything about money
yeah and is that money will not bring
your happiness but with the money you
can bring happiness in around you so you
can you know how people what did you
what was the biggest thing that you
learned from spending time with Robert
Kiyosaki well he was a bit at the Friday
when we have the dinner he was like a
bit not really tough but he kind of was
something which you don't speak on the
big stage and he explained that actually
you know there are things going around
the back hurting to say like that which
you know people doesn't realize and
these big guys which make the games
while I'm talking is the investors
actually which they understand that to
invest will help you to save rather than
work for money
he's an idea of investing money in
businesses group taking a business from
you know as a little bit crew growing
and make it big and that will bring more
to the other people's yeah bring you
know jobs and all the stuff but on that
evening one of the the good thing I
learned I liked it was the fact that you
know it's not too late it's not too late
to start to invest is obviously is
investing a lot in in in properties be
dry but in the meantime investing in
stock markets and also but just a little
present of his hasit is there but it's
not too late to get out yeah and invest
in do something I mean as long as you
understand that is it's not wrong but as
long as you work for money you'll chase
the money yeah and what was it like as a
person because I know you were very
intimate with him and you got well well
he's 17 now respect is a bi guv
yeah call friendly to be honest we're
friendly was a bit of fun there because
in that room I think we've been about 40
people just five of us five of us we've
been from Britain so yeah you kept -
suvir's yeah yeah yeah you will see how
virtually because when you when we first
met at your little Romanian voice oh
yeah it's too good to be true and all
this stuff to be honest like what would
you have thought sorry what would you
have thought if you fast forward in a
year or two and you knew that you'd of
six probably deals you would you return
in over a quarter of a million pounds
with your plumbing business your people
working for you you're having dinner
with people like Robert Kiyosaki you
were sat here now on winners on a
Wednesday like would you have believed
it and what would you have thought no
because I did I did all the time to let
that voice to say to me a is impossible
yeah you know I think that that was one
of my mistakes you know leave that voice
is too good to be true or is too
difficult to get there but once I step
out that out of my comfort zone and you
know I become vulnerable and you know
expose myself then I realized that the
things are possible I know it's a bit of
work I mean with the plumbing and
heating company he's not I can't say
there was like that
yeah bit of hard work I do have the
right people around me I'm by the way
there's a new for you I'm with one year
coaching with with Rex fantastic yeah
Rex is from the Academy yes I met him
there so the thing is I really want to
to be advised by the best yeah and I
learned that you know before I was
thinking I'm the smartest guys in my own
company I know everything but there's a
kind of risky yeah and now I can say now
that I have people like one of my main
people he's much better than me in what
he's doing yeah so I kind of replaced
myself with someone better than me yeah
yeah and I have that time to stay at the
back now to see what's wrong was good
and you know - yeah - put it there it's
so I mean for me like when we first met
you know if I mean people from Romania
just learnt in the process of learning
to speak the language with no money you
know yeah it'll be easy to say you know
what don't pay me for your advanced
training but but seeing people like you
that have paid because you've put you
know you've pat you've paid our training
company us but it's paid off in
dividends yeah I mean who is it is wrong
to think that money is everything is a
knowledge yeah
you you done you're you're the reason
the challenge yeah finally a challenge
it's not about money it's about what you
know your knowledge case you know with
your knowledge you can stand over and
over from different places in different
businesses so ah that's why I try to
take the Maxima I joined academy I know
there was a bit of financially cause
here but I say you know what I'm willing
to learn and to learn a lot yeah and to
take all that well when I came first
time and I saw your business how you run
the business like whoa that's kind of
easy to put in my company why I'll nod
it for my compare while close my company
if there is a way to do it you know
different because as I said being part
of the Academy it was as a family for me
I was feeling more comfortable to ask
question sometimes you think that your
questions are be silly in it yeah and
you don't want to go to a stranger to
network and ask a silly question being
part of the Academy was a bit more
friendly that the rule was and you know
start to speak with people I'm Alistair
with Paul and I'm different people
different backgrounds they teach you a
lot yes
so you have a comfortable place right to
actually ask question and no all off
about you know your question and they
will help you actually so yeah and
that's yes as well I mean you're a very
driven switched-on guy you're very
hardworking but we had to kick your ass
they elected I dragged you to Africa
well I'd remember when I kept yes oh you
all's on
York that rent trainings and he was
flooring what do you think I was like at
that point I was still having a
struggling with the company with the
jobs and yeah the people I had that time
I was kicking your I was like all the
time it's supposed to be all the time
they're on the phone and I was like oh
my gosh so be one week away that would
be difficult yeah the job will not go
ahead no the little boy Romanian voice
yeah slowly slowly you know I let it go
and I was like you know I have to do it
because you know you never know where
we'll be
you have this chance again yeah you know
that was life-changing to be honest
Africa was a good experience fantastic
questions if you will give if you were
advising someone that was in a similar
boat to you when you first came to
England very little English no money at
all but a lot of Drive and a fire in
your belly what advice would you give to
your younger self I think he's just to
believe in yourself and to dream a big
dream big one of the key point in in my
journey was like I never ever stopped
listening to people saying that you will
not be able to do things all the time I
was believing myself that I can move on
I remember starting on the first company
that was the notch in nature or getting
35 pounds a day was you know peanuts
money yeah I was just myself that time
but done on the line after six year I I
get my gas qualification plumbing
qualification and you know I mean 200
300 pounds a day it was just the fact
that I was I was believing in myself
it's true there were my wife believed as
well and push me a lot and support me a
lot but I think the key point is you
know don't listen to the little voice or
the people which and if you have deeds
the circle of people these people which
actually they drag you down they are
negative you know just get rid of them
even even they are your friends and they
step out of a lot of people circles
which actually didn't bring me anything
good
I just you know leave them aside and
move on move on yeah and I try to focus
to stay next to the positive people of
people which they believe thing is uh I
think cause a key say no you know reach
dad he's reached that he said that what
you have here is one of the most
powerful thing in the whole world
yeah so if you if you leave the voices
around you to put you down
yeah that's bad so you just have to so
you have to be born believe in yourself
yes to get around people that believe in
you as well
yes final question whenever we have
people that are successful in business
through property they never just go on
financially free now or I've done this
now I've got this I know that I'm gonna
stop you're still very driven what is
your biggest reason why right for me the
reason I joined academia no not join the
economy what's your biggest reason why
you're continuing to power my company's
self is called ACF plumbing and heating
so ACF stands for my daughter's which
they all say start with a yeah Christina
and fluorine so I when I build this
company when I started company was a bit
of family business around company so I
was thinking you know what I have to
leave something behind me so you never
know down on the few years my family
were really girls in involving the
business but I want to do something
different yeah yeah and he's not just
about money because in the end the money
will come or go yeah but I want to do
something yeah I want you know the is
not to get famous is just to add
something extra to the people nepo
saying you know what that company
whatever that guy was just like
unbelievable you know we run last before
Christmas we run a promotion every
people below 60 a ting if they have any
financial struggles something we'll do a
bowl of a service bowl of free of charge
we really want to add and that was it
wasn't a plan of advertising or business
no I feel one day I remember calling the
guy who run my Facebook I say John we
have to put this on I want to offer free
border services yeah you know supply me
sir
to my community because is true you grow
in a community that come to give me give
me a lot like the the place where I am
and I feel that I have to give something
back I love that man
legacy yes for your kids I love the way
that we're changing the way that
business entrepreneurs think which is to
just give value because if you give
enough value the money will follow oh
yeah you will reap what you sow so yeah
god bless you thanks so much for coming
on the show man I'm sorry thank you so
much for watching the video that is the
reason why I'm doing this your success
is my oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course comment on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for
two days to help you get started you can
see what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out